Vào vùng gió trình mới rất càng mù tría và thái lăng tại cú bình dời sáng ngày 1,
tăng thông mẹ hai tích tục làm tình hình ảnh ninh của bực trở nên càng khăn.
Theo các báo cá bán đầu, ý nhăn năm người đã thì mạng của bốn dân thường
các mù tría và một bình sĩ thái lăng.
Tất cả một gió trình mới giãn tởi lạng sống xơ tảng lượng tại cả hay nữa.
Giờ chức càng mù tría thông báo, hôm 1 mi một trong hộ dân tảy tình,
ổ đà, mình trầy, đã được xơ tán.
Trung khi đó, con độ thái lăng trở biết hơn 8,5 lăng dân thường
tại bốn viện biên dời đang trong diện phải xơ tán.
Bởi hơn 7 lăng dân người đưa vào các khu bực trua ấn tạm thời.
Thái lăng tạm thời đón gửa hơn xong trà bố mi mốt trường học tại các tình biên dời
và chuẩn bị cơ phương ảnh sự phòng.
Đáng chú ý, chú thích thử viện, các buồn chia tất trung xem,
đã đưa ra càng báo cương sẵn, tuyên bố thích lập lăng dân đầu với cuối sử.
Cái hay bên đầu luyến tiến cá mục nhau vì phạm thật tượng bắn,
ra ra tuyên mố mạnh tạo quan hại xong xác.
Đồng thời tiêu gọi hành nước kiểm tri tui đàn ruy trì kinh liên là và tận dụng các cơ chế hiện có ở đây,
giải quyết xung đồ.